si leurs aînés sont similaires et
compatibles pourquoi pas j'ai pas
forcément d'avis sur la question je suis
pas plus politique que ça ferait si
c'est pour des bonnes oeuvres d'art des
bonnes raisons les bonnes idées pour
pâques un parti au pouvoir en france et
qui ont à dire qu'ils balayent nos
libertés que c'était rabat ça peut être
moi ça ne me choque pas ça me choque pas
puisque c'est vrai sincèrement je pense
qu'effectivement dans la politique ça
s'est toujours fait ce genre de choses
là même c'est vrai que moi je suis plus
à ne pas vraiment croire en la politique
française donc ça c'est pas un sujet qui
me passionne énormément mais ça m'étonne
même pas parce que la politique c'est
vrai que ben que des groupes s'allient
pour faire voir plus de puissance et
c'est quelque chose imite qui s'est déjà
fait et qui se fera encore et qui se
fera donc c'est tout à fait normal enfin
niveau politique faire des alliances moi
ça ne me choque pas je pense que pour la
politique oui maintenant est ce que je
suis pour
je pense que non je pense que chaque
partie devrait promouvoir ses habits ses
idées ses opinions et pas faire des
alliances pour avoir plus de puissance
parce que en soit ça peut aider mais le
mieux ce serait quand même de promouvoir
des idées qui sont qui sont vraiment des
idées qui sont positifs qui sont en
rapport avec le parti est pas faire des
alliances pour justement gagné en
puissance mais plutôt qu'à une option ce
grâce à ses propres idées ses propres
opinions
tu avais partie ce qu'on appelle des
tactiques électorales à savoir que pour
casse et au premier tour que chacun
garde son identité
j'adore ça c'est normal alors au
deuxième tour qu'a parti je vais je vais
surtout pas cité de noms mais qu'à
partis se mettre avec un hôte pour
défendre ses idées principales cyr que
se rapproche d'un autre parti avec
lequel il aurait un certain nombre
d'affinités fait partie de la tactique
électorale et ça me paraît pas ça ne
paraît pas idiots qu'ils le fassent
c'est de bonne guerre c'est de la
tactique électorale c'est bon dans la
mesure où on est au pied du mur et que
l'on veut que l'on veut faire passer ses
idées même si ça n'est pas saisie
intégralement mais que l'oreille
apporter du poids dans la balance pour
défendre l'essentiel de ses idées me
paraît normal pas je pense qu'il va le
garder leur siège
c'est tout mais s'il y avait vraiment un
bénéfice quelconque pour la population
ça se saurait
c'est à dire qu'il faut bien s'entendre
quand même
parce que les six divisions massa mène à
rien de toute façon on est coincé il ya
toujours eu des alliances et je pense
effectivement que c'est un moyenne
devant d'avoir d'avoir des forces
bien sûr je pense que les vivants que
c'est à dire ceux ponctuelles que ça n'a
pas d'incidence sur la présidentielle
par exemple c'est un peu compliqué à
dire je pense que aujourd'hui et
beaucoup de divisions au sein des partis
politiques et on a tendance à les
parties ont tendance à ce ratage et
beaucoup surtout avec la polémique du
rassemblement national qui se
rattacherait potentiellement avec le
avec la république en marche mais
honnêtement je sais pas trop ce que ça
va donner au niveau des élections mais
je pense que ça risque de prêter à
confusion pour beaucoup de gens par
rapport à leur identité leur envie de se
rattacher à tel ou tel parti
je pense qu'on a tendance à créer plus
de communautés dans les communautés au
sein des partis politiques ce qui fait
que aujourd'hui moins de gens les gens
qui sont plus neutres qui ont tendance à
vouloir mélanger plusieurs idées doivent
se rattacher à des partis qui parfois ne
sont pas que leurs idées et on lance des
inclus et donc ont tendance à se séparer
politiquement de plus deux parties plus
- des limites et on va dire